le secrétaire général de la cstm
mécontents la question sous travaux lui
semble de plus en plus problématique
bertrand cambuci expriment très
clairement son album il faut que cette
entreprise sur deux les yeux parce que
il as causé suffisamment à la population
nous avons créé avec le golf qui est
déposée déjà largement mieux là
aujourd'hui nous avons dit si y'a rien
de fait si la société sur travaux si la
société nous avons n'a pas la preuve
comme respectueux alité à lui à
montreuil et il lui a demandé de réparer
les bus parce qu'elle sait ce que c'est
pas le contrôle technique qui va vous
dire parce qu'il ya des points de
contrôle technique de ne contrôle pas
réparé baichoo medien bichot au nom si
vendredi
on est dans cette situation là la csn a
en gold et à ce moment là c'est tout le
réseau touché puisque comme il ya
d'autres encore christie's en même temps
eh ben on va entrer en conflit avec ses
autres albums l'un des quatre co
traitant de la cft hu a régulièrement
fait l'actualité au moins depuis 2015
doit de retrait mouvement de grève des
salariés qui dénoncent les conditions de
travail et de sécurité
mais quant à faire sortir ces travaux
hommes de la cft eu en trois nuls le
président ne comprends pas cette
attitude
je dis que nous avions acheté six bus à
raison de 84 ans d'âge aujourd'hui nous
avons deux mécaniciens notre actif qui
est par les bus en temps et en heure
donc je ne peux pas prendre aujourd'hui
renier audio que tous nos bus sont
problématiques
aujourd'hui il faut que ce travail
sortent du réseau écoutez que ce
monsieur a toujours été méchant qui ne
soit un jaloux ou pas aujourd'hui s'il y
va de ses responsabilités qu'il me fasse
sortir des raisons pourquoi pas je suis
prêt à l'entendre accepté pourquoi pas
le président de la cpu et lui ne tient
pas à s'exprimer
des pourparlers sont en cours en
attendant les usagers sont prévenus les
perturbations sont loin d'être terminées